我今天看到一個蠻有意思的案例，叫做「Pi pod」。它在 Hacker News 上面被提出來，很有趣的一點是，現在大家談 AI agent 都覺得好像是巨頭的服務，需要一直燒錢。
嗯，對，而且很多時候你用那些服務，就等於把自己的資料、自己的模型都綁死在他們那裡。換個供應商可能又要重新來過。
沒錯，這「Pi pod」反而是鼓勵大家自己架設 AI agent 的環境，甚至提供開源程式碼。它讓你在自己的伺服器上跑，創造一個個獨立的沙盒。
等等，這裡我有疑問。現在大家都追求輕量化、雲端服務，它反其道而行，要我們自己架，這不會很麻煩嗎？一般公司哪有那個技術人員去弄這些？
其實原文有提到，它的設計目標就是「簡單運行」。作者 Evan 說，他希望任何對 Pi 有興趣的人都能自己架設起來。這點其實不容易做到。
「簡單運行」怎麼說呢？聽起來還是需要一些技術背景吧。我猜啦，對一般中小企業來說，可能還是會覺得門檻很高。
這點我是信了，因為原文的確強調了「自託管版本設計得很簡單」。而且它強調的是「自主部署」，讓你擁有真正的控制權和隱私，這對企業來說是很重要的。
嗯，這確實是一個誘人的點。如果我的公司資料非常敏感，又想用 AI agent，那自己架設就很有吸引力。但成本呢？自己架伺服器、維護，這費用會比用現成的服務便宜嗎？
原文有提到，像現在很多解決方案都是「按量計費」，你用多少付多少錢。但自己架設，雖然前期有投入，長期來看，可以大幅降低這種「被綁定」的營運成本。
被綁定這點我很有感。就像訂閱服務一樣，一開始覺得划算，結果累積起來也是一筆錢。而且服務商一旦漲價或改變規則，你就只能被動接受。
所以 Pi pod 的做法其實出乎意料，它不是要跟你搶客戶，而是希望大家都能「擁有」自己的 AI agent 環境。這點很特別。
對，這跟傳統軟體公司的邏輯很不一樣。它讓我想起以前一些開源軟體，一開始可能沒那麼普及，但慢慢會因為自主性高而吸引一批使用者。
沒錯。如果我是創業者，我會從這裡學到一件事：當大公司把持市場的時候，不要跟他們正面對決，而是想想有沒有哪些需求是被忽略的？例如像這種對「控制權」和「成本」極度敏感的企業。
嗯，這確實給了我們一個啟示。不一定要去追求最前沿、最高大上的技術，有時候「實用、可控、低成本」反而能打開一片市場。
而且它還能讓你「完全客製化」你的 AI agent 環境。這點是很多現成的服務做不到的。如果你有特殊需求，可以自己調整。
那對於一般上班族來說，這個概念能怎麼帶入工作或生活呢？我們又沒有伺服器可以自己架。
我覺得，可以從「減少依賴」的角度來思考。很多時候我們工作上會依賴某些特定軟體或供應商，會不會有機會去研究一些開源或替代方案，讓自己更自主？
你的意思是，例如我們常用的協作工具，如果費用越來越高，我們是不是也可以去看看有沒有類似「Pi pod」這種，可以自己架設或至少數據能掌握在自己手上的方案？
對，就是這個意思。不被某個單一供應商綁死。這對個人和企業來說，都是一種控制權的奪回。
好像也提醒了我們，在面對各種技術服務的時候，多問一句「我能不能有更好的自主權和控制權」。